eu vim do interior e carrega e me
orgulho e amor por ter nascido onde eu
nasci e aprendi que possui sertanejo eu
tenho meu próprio traquejo e um jeito de
ser que matou tamente confessam ser de
lampejo pois ser do sertão como eu já
disse um outro verso é um dom divino tão
grande quase do tamanho do universo e ao
inverso do que pensam de onde eu vim
felicidade é sobrenome um bom sorriso
nos consome e não é por falta de garra
que alguns infelizmente ainda vivem com
fome
a água por lá época e disso todo mundo
sabe mas a gente não deixa que acabe
pois desde muito pequeno aprendeu a
economizar vovó vivia me falar que nunca
vi um menino novo morrer por um pouco
labutar e que era melhor segurar no cabo
da enxada do que viver na rua vadiar e
assim eu fui crescendo sem deixar de
estudar
sabendo que pára em frente nem sempre é
ruim ter que voltar mas não se pode
deslumbrar da fé em nosso deus de todo
dia agradecer pois na cabeça pra onde
quer que a gente for é a humildade e o
amor que faz qualquer homem vencer eu
nasci num canto de bahia onde chove
somente uma vez ao ano
eu sou de guanambi e por lá
esse fenômeno é tão aguardado por nós
que quando a água resolve cair do céu
todo mundo vai para a janela assistiu me
recordo de meu pai que falava são pedro
em fim lembrou da gente e nós sempre
aprendemos a conviver com essa chuva vez
ao ano
e aquilo pra gente é um evento uma coisa
tão grandiosa que eu aprendi a ver aí
que para a gente do sertão a
simplicidade literalmente mora nas
pequenas coisas
eu defino sertão não como um canto de
brasil onde costuma chover pouco pra mim
sertão é estado de espírito e pode
habitar o coração de pessoas nascidas em
roraima rio grande do sul japão
austrália e estados unidos
sertão é carregar em si sorriso na cara
coragem para enfrentar a vida
persistência pois esse é o lema
o sertanejo um pouco de malícia pois às
vezes é necessário e fé seja em alguém
em uma força superior e principalmente
em você mesmo e o sertanejo ele tem algo
que eu acho excepcional é que
diariamente acorda por volta das 5 horas
da manhã
coloca a enxada no ombro e vai capinar
la na sua propriedade naquela caatinga
só tem seis meses que não chove e não
tem previsão de chuva ele vai capinar o
chance kuê parece que ali sem meia uma
das mais belas coisas que o sertanejo
sabe plantar
ela se chama esperança pois o sertanejo
definir as suas escolhas
ele é cheio de escolhas eu como
sertanejo que sou hoje com 25 anos
aos 14 resolvi tomar uma decisão que
mudou o rumo da minha vida me recordo
que na minha casa tinha um dicionário
ainda tem até hoje muito grande e um dia
eu tomei a decisão que eu ia tirar uma
palavra da minha vida e que eu tinha que
fazer isso de forma simbólica eu abrir
aquele dicionário na página 614 e ali
estava a palavra desistir cuidadosamente
eu retirei essa página adicionar you
rasguei ela e guardei esse pequeno papel
picado dentro de uma caixinha de madeira
e está guardada até hoje
a vida é feita de escolhas o sertanejo
faz a dele quando vai semear o chão seco
e eu fiz quando resolvi colocar aquele
aquela página do dicionário numa
caixinha e pretendo nunca mais ter que
usar um do ex para colá lo no sertão
também tem algo muito importante
uma árvore que veio lá de mandar ficar
na áfrica trazida na época da escravidão
e talvez por ter vindo à época de tanta
dor
ela trouxe para o brasil um sentimento
de que o homem do sertão quando assim vê
faz o coração brilhar
o flamboyant para quem não conhece mas o
ano todo seco sanfoneiro as pessoas que
passa na estrada falou naquela árvore e
morreu
o flamboyant tem muito
homem do sertão ou seria o homem do
sertão que tem muito do flamboyant
só que basta a primeira chuva pois quem
é do sertão da caatinga sabe o quê que
uma chuva faz no sertão
basta uma para que aquela árvore
aparente móvel aparentemente morta se
enche de folhas verdes e depois de ruby
todas as folhas verdes e fique florida
com uma rosa vermelha que além de exalar
cheiro exalava esperança pois assim como
sertão o flamboyant não sabe o que é
desistir e para carregar esse sentimento
que o flamboyant também carrega ele tem
de ter a percepção persistência
eu escolhi dedicar à minha vida a falar
do nordeste
há cinco anos a minha vida minha rotina
é ficar cerca de 20 dias fora de casa
na casa de tantas pessoas que me recebem
foi uma das decisões mais acertadas que
eu já tive na vida
e aí eu comecei a cada dia mais criar um
caso de amor com esse pedaço do nosso
brasil
o cheiro do requeijão recém saído do
forno com rapadura ralada uma coisa
inesquecível assim como aquela manga que
nós temos o prazer de tirar do pé e ali
mesmo se lambuzar debaixo de uma sombra
frondosa ou então uma galinha caipira
feita no fogão de lenha com pirão zinho
pimentinha rosinho e aquela cachacinha
que é feita naquele engenho movido a boi
e tudo isso em comum têm o trabalho é um
povo que trabalha muito sanfoneiro tem o
dna do trabalho são doutores da arte de
viver
gente que nunca nem teve a chance de
passar na porta de universidade mas tem
doutorado na lida com a vida no laçadas
dificuldades no arredio daquilo que
faria muitos de nós chorar
eles são doutores dariam aula a qualquer
um de nós por aqui
doutores doutores que inclusive aprendem
a tocar a sanfona sem nunca na vida ter
passado por um professor
até nisso eles são doutores e as maiores
maior
os momentos que eu vivi junto com essa
gente sanfoneiro sempre teve o som desse
instrumento de seu luiz gonzaga e sivuca
dominguinhos um instrumento que ajuda a
contar a história da nossa gente e mesmo
acordando 5 horas da manhã na enxada até
seis horas da tarde
o sertanejo tem se o sorriso no rosto
para chegar a ditar de final de tarde
vena o sol vir à lua e dançar um forró
porque felicidade também é combustível
de vida como um dia me disse dona cota
96 anos lado da cidade de cafarnaum ela
falou mateus
a vida é a coisa mais fácil do mundo mas
nós gosta de ficar dificultando as
coisas e ficar arrumando problema quando
a gente vê a vida las a gente leva
embora e nós nunca mais tem acordo com
ela ou gente como por seu mauro marreca
lado município de caracol no sul do
piauí que há sete anos não plantam
colhem uma roça de milho todo ano perde
perde pede mas ele está preparando o
solo agora porque o lado o solo vai vim
se deus quiser
a fartura que há oito anos bateu em sua
porta
nessas andanças eu também tive a
oportunidade de conversar com gente que
convive que tem diariamente a
convivência de uma das coisas mais
difíceis que alguém pode ter que a fome
gente que não tem o que comer
e acreditem muita gente assim gente que
mesmo com seis filhos dentro de casa se
você bater na porta da casa dele só tive
uma panela de feijão ele divide com você
porque ele sabe que pode ter pouco mas é
devido porque o sertanejo tem fé e se
ele tem fé em da ele também tem fé em
receber hoje em dia com o negócio de
internet o povo anda letrado fala tudo
que quer do jeito que quer a hora que
quer como quer
eu queria muito que aqueles que bradam
por lá falando mal do nordeste me desce
o prazer de seguia deles eu queria levá
los para o sertão que fica no nordeste
além do mar
viajar às vezes mil e 100 mil e duzentos
quilombo lugar
tem nem estrada para chegar e que vive
um agente que acorda às 5 horas da manhã
que vai lá que luta que capina que não
sei que queria eu queria que essa pessoa
junto comigo passasse lá sete dias
dividida naquela mesma panela de feijão
eu queria que essas pessoas tivessem lá
comigo vendo o que é aquilo ali vendo o
que quer não deixa água nem pb a essas
pessoas eu faço o convite venham para o
nordeste além do mar e se apaixonem por
que quem tem a mínima sensibilidade cria
um caso de amor com o sertão
nessas nossas andanças eu também percebi
que o sertanejo errante porque tem gente
que às vezes nossas e defende tanto os
sertanejos a também deve ser um santo
beatificado estamos longe de sermos
santos estamos longe de sermos seres
beatificados nós erramos nós falhamos
nós perdemos e isso por um único motivo
porque nós certa mesmos somos pessoas
nós somos gente como qualquer outro ser
humano do mundo nós temos carne e osso
nós nascemos e nós morremos e um dos
principais defeitos do mundo hoje em dia
são faleiro é porque muita gente vive
uma vida toda pensando que não vai
morrer do sertão a emoção de ser desse
pedaço de chão de todos esses
aprendizados vi cenas que me marcaram e
vão ficar eternamente em minha memória
como por exemplo de dona maria na zona
rural de cocos pela primeira vez com 89
anos de idade ela ligou o interruptor da
luz da casa dela viu luz em casa ou de
dona ana com 65 lado município de
gilbués em piauí que nunca foi na escola
mas formou filho em medicina ou então do
seu pedro que mesmo morando muito
próximo ao rio carinhanha no município
de carinhanha pela primeira vez teve
água encanada em casa somos sertanejo
senhores todos nós e aqueles que ainda
não se descobriram fica o meu real
convite pra quê embarque nessa onda de
ser tão acredite muita gente por aí
teria n motivos a mais para desistir
pelos seus sonhos e não desiste
e aí fica a minha reflexão aos senhores
será que as nossas dificuldades
será que aquilo que nos aflige é grande
o suficiente para nos fazer parar
lembrem-se pensem reflitam
nem mesmo a seca quando nada nasça faz o
flamboyant deixar de ter fé que em breve
ele lá ir a florir e por isso eu
concluiu dizendo que repare que toda a
estrada um dia foi caminho que nem todo
o vôo de passarinho e nem toda a lavoura
é colheita certa assunto pois não é toda
semente que vai germinar chuva fina não
é forte mas também faz molhar e nem todo
o frio segura na coberta pois um
sonhador pra sonhar tem de saber que pra
fazer acontecer a persistência é o
caminho para em frente nem sempre é ruim
ter de volta vai insistindo que tu chega
lá nem que foi devagarinho e por isso
senhores eu digo embora lá vai sonhando
que uma hora o treino acerto muito
obrigado e boa noite
[Aplausos]
[Música]